are you getting recognized now and you
go so does anyone recognized you from
people have recognized me but it was
funny me mum dad my twin brother
Christian and my agent Jude we went to
Korean barbecue we'll more New York man
pretty nice
but we went there and there was this
there was like group of these six like
you know mid-twenties you know having a
fun time and they were taking shots and
stuff and they were really loud and we
somehow ended up talking because my mum
ended up taking a shot with them one
shot though your mother straight your
mom needs some twenty year old guys if
you like you want to take a shot and
mom's like okay so Amundson shot them
and they're like oh yeah so what are you
guys doing in New York like are we here
for the Depot to premiere and um do you
like oh I heard it's really amazing this
is a really good cause I'm like here
make sure to go and watch and they're
like cool yeah we will yeah I'm like
yeah go watch it yeah remember this face
then I okay yeah I'll go watch it so
yeah
wait a minute you never told them that
you were in the movie no no all you did
was say go see Deadpool came in with the
space I remember this fan yeah now
that's the part usually they would say
why are you in it did they ask that I
will just like no we got a lot of shots
they were IV I love that they're
probably watching the movie like still
not understanding why did he tell us to
watch it's only right now are they
getting it well I'm very happy for you
you're in Deadpool 2 it's in theaters
right now have you seen it you think yes
I've seen it three times you've seen it
three times and do you like it yeah I
wouldn't see it three times if I didn't
yeah not true you're in it yeah yeah
everyone loves it Julian Dennison thank
you for being here we'll be right back
tuxedo and
[Applause]
you